un peu plus de cinq minutes pour
comprendre les enjeux de ce projet du
pipeline énergie est jean thomas bernard
economy spécialiste en énergie adversité
d'ottawa pour soir monsieur bernard
bonsoir
alors on va on va tout expliquer vous
allez en fait tout expliqué revoyons si
vous le voulez bien sur une carte
ce dont on parle ce projet de pipeline
énergie est tombée on va le voir tout de
suite iad une partie existante et il ya
une partie à construire
oui parce que derrière ce projet là il
ya la conversion de gaz ou un gazoduc
pour l'emmener à transporter du pétrole
alors ce gazoduc l'avenue désuet c'était
l'arrivée du gaz de schiste
particulièrement dans le nord-est des
etats-unis dans la région de la
pennsylvanie l'ohio est à présent
l'ontario et le québec peuvent
s'approvisionner à un moindre coût à ses
plus proches que dans l'ouest où on
retraite où notre approvisionnement à
venir jusqu'à une année ou deux là on a
vu monsieur bernard les réactions un
très très vive dans l'oise du pays quand
denis coderre a dit nous on n'en veut
pas dans la région de montréal pourquoi
si si stratégique pourquoi si si
important bien la motivation de tous les
projets de pipelines qui ont été
présentés jusqu'à ce moment parce qu'il
ya eu plusieurs projets c'est qu' il n'y
a pas suffisamment de capacités pour
sortir le pétrole de l'alberta et
l'effet de ça c'est que le prix du
pétrole
reçus par les producteurs albertain est
plus faible que le prix mondial à ce que
le prix que l'on s'y étaient tous les
jours la soie le brent soit le double
des biens le pétrole en alberta une fois
que l'on corrige la police avant ciel de
qualité ne reçoit pas ce prix là ya pas
suffisamment de capacité de sorte que
les personnes ou les organisations des
droits sur le transport du pétrole
sur la base des plaines peuvent exiger
un tarif plus élevé qui est comparable
aux moyens alternatifs qui est le train
ça coûte plus cher de voyager faire
voyager le pétrole par train que par
pipeline
ce que les détenteurs de droit en poche
un bénéfice là
donc le projet le tracé que l'on voit à
l'écran actuellement il est important
dans la mesure aussi où d'autres projets
de pipelines ont du plomb dans l aile
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire oui le
premier projet qui a été présenté on se
relève déjà depuis sept ou huit ans
c'était dans les premières années de
monsieur obama
c'est le kyste historique celle qui
aurait été de l'alberta à houston au
texas bien là ça c'était le premier
choix de la part des producteurs
canadiens mais aussi des raffineries
américaines parce que environ 50% de la
capacité de raffinage aux états unis se
situe dans la région de houston et les
raffineries de cette région sont équipés
pour transformer du pétrole au tel qu'on
en produit à partir des sables
bitumineux ce projet ce projet là et est
à peu près mort on sait qu obama dit non
pourrait-il revivre à moyen terme bien
ça va dépendre évidemment de la position
du nouveau président on peut spéculer
lui il a refusé ça monsieur obama pour
plaire à sa base environnementalistes à
l'intérieur du parti démocrate
cette base là ne disparaîtra pas parce
que ce sera un nouveau candidat que ce
soit monsieur sainte deux joues à madame
clinton je pense qu'elle sera très très
active
donc ça n'augure pas bien pour le
ce projet là très bien l'autre tuyaux
pour sortir le pétrole albertain
mais vers l'ouest c'était le nom d'une
gateway c'est accepter par le fils de
l'énergie du canada mais là ça ça ce but
ce projet là à l'acceptabilité sociale
en trombe
oui en effet c'est ce projet est accepté
mais on lui a soumis bonne liste de
conditions et la plus importante je
crois c'est de en convenir convenir des
ententes avec les communautés des
premières nations qui sont situés dans
le nord de la colombie onic un endroit
où est présentement il n'ya pas de
pipeline
donc il faut partir à neuf dans cette
région là et même si le projet est
accepté il ya à peu près un âge moyen un
peu plus on est très loin de voir les
les machines s'opérer au niveau du sol
pour faire de la place aux peuples non
plus impatience du côté des albertains
et le trench mountain c'est quoi c'est
un autre tuyau oui il existe déjà un
peuple n qui va de l'alberta à burnaby
qui est
c'était une ville avoisinante de
vancouver et il y avait du raffinage
dans ce coin-là plus on pourrait
exporter par navire donc sain
un peu plein d'une capacité d'environ
300 milles baril on voulait emprunter le
tracé qui existe déjà pour augmenter la
capacité dont qui lui ajouter 1 600
milles baril est ici la ville de
de vancouver particulièrement s'est
opposé en utilisant l'argument qui est
fun bien monsieur coderre que
effectivement on n'avait pas
suffisamment de mis en place de mesures
préventives
si jamais il survenait un déversement
dans le port de vancouver
alors on comprend mieux il revient au
début de notre discussion comprend mieux
l'importance stratégique pour un
transcanada d'énergie est là oui parce
que effectivement on peut se demander
les prix du pétrole sont très bas
présentement alors pourquoi est ce qu'on
voudrait construire un peuple est bien
la production avait augmenté beaucoup
dans les dernières années là où à
l'époque où le prêter 100 105 dollars et
c'est dans ces circonstances là qu'on
n'avait pas suffisamment de capacité
qu'on a vu augmenter le transport par
train donc même si présentement il n'ya
pas de projets d'expansion des sables
bitumineux en alberta dans le contexte
du prix actuel bien même dans ce
contexte difficile il ya encore surplus
de capacité de production et le prix en
alberta y d'environ 10 dollar plus
faible que le prix mondial à cause de
ces contrats est là il ya les semaine
dernière le prix tu es 26 dollars on a
vu 26 dollars ça voulait dire qu'en
alberta
ils étaient de l'ordre d'à peu près 15
dollars alors c'est quand même très
faible ça ceci ici monsieur bernard ce
projet allait de l'avant l'admettons
tout le monde il rassuré à qui le
pipeline bénéficierait difficile
évidemment faut revenir à la motivation
on veut que les producteurs albert t
reçoivent le prix mondial alors
l'épreuve les premières personnes
les premiers s'organise en bénéficier
c'est les producteurs albertain
évidemment greffer à ça il ya les
revenus que l'alberta reçoit sous forme
de redevance parce que les redevances
sont en fonction de la valeur qui est
extraite donc le grand albert terre
recevraient plus de redevances il ya
aussi les impôts qui sont perçus à la
fois par les impôts survenue de
coopération particuliers qui sont perçus
à la fois par le grand
alberta et le granma fédéral et à
travers les revenus additionnels que
l'alberta pour gagner il y aurait
évidemment en effet à travers la
péréquation qui donc le québec recevrait
plus un jean parce que l'alberta serait
plus riche d'ukraine différents le
différentiel serait plus grands il y
aurait plus de péréquation apprécié pour
les provinces dites pauvres
ouais il est probable dit pas où c'est
truqué provinces canadiennes à
l'exception des provinces qui produisent
du pétrole et du gaz a volume suis assez
l'école où danic l'alberta la
saskatchewan et terre neuve tous les
autres reçoivent très bien je bernard on
entend coller la bc pour mieux
comprendre ce débat là qui est loin
d'être terminée merci beaucoup à bien
tous ces magouilleurs vous remercie
bonne soirée et en voir